what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest developments in the demon slayer
story things are really heating up fast
right now if you enjoyed these Demon
Slayer videos make sure to smash that
like button because it really helps with
the YouTube algorithm if you have and be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
won't know when new videos come out you
can now find their videos in audio form
on Spotify and Apple music
just look up anime out for our audio or
click the links in the description and
you can download and listen to our
videos before they even come out on
YouTube I'm really glad that we've set
this up because now if a video gets a
false copyright strike and gets taken
down for a week or two you'll still be
able to listen to it there keep in mind
there will be manga spoilers in this
video now without further ado let's jump
into it if you remember during the last
chapter we got Eagles back story and it
truly set him up as one of the most
tragic characters in the series he feels
unworthy of love and he's trying to die
in the hopes that his death will cleanse
him of his and his family's sins it's
very sad to begin with but it's even
sadder that he had to see meet suti the
woman he loves get hurt by the demon
King of Pop he ended up leaving her in
the care of some demons their core
members while he himself continued to
fight moves on and that brings us to
this chapter where the battle between
the opie pillars and the even more Opie
Mouzon rages on in the first manga panel
we seen as Zuko
she stopped running she's sweating and
she's gripping her right I remember she
was running to help ton judo whose right
eye was badly wounded and affected the
infection was spreading and Mouzon
already wrote him off as dead the fact
that mystical is gripping her own right
eye and has stopped running seems to
suggest that she somehow senses the
seriousness of ton zeroes wounds it
could even be seen as suggesting that
she has stopped running because she
thinks she's already too late again are
absent don't think hunter will die but
it definitely doesn't look good for him
at this point then we jump to see how
other weaker Demon Slayer core members
are helping they are keeping people away
from the battle so that the pillars can
just focus on fighting moves on rather
than on trying to help people
everyone has their role to play these
guys are telling people that the ground
caved in so they should go and get
shelter people worried that it might be
a
but the demon center core members ensure
them that there isn't a fire to keep
them from panicking if they actually
knew what was happening they probably
freak out even harder than if there was
a fire they may have seen fires in the
past but they probably never saw a human
eating demon with tentacle-like limbs
who can murder them all in seconds
people start wondering who these
strange-looking people are meaning that
the even ser corps members they ask them
if they are the police and our Demon
Slayer boys say that they've come at the
request of the police which is
believable enough some demons their core
members are trying to see if anyone
needs help they luckily don't see anyone
caught in some of the recently collapsed
buildings another points out that that's
because there are fewer people out that
early in the day remember the Sun hasn't
even risen yet however then they hear a
cat meowing under the wreckage one
member helps it out and then tries to
stop it since it is going in the
direction of the fight but the cat keeps
going we see that it has a bag on its
back you may remember this cat it's name
is cha-cha Maru
this cat was tomorrow's assistant and we
saw him as early as chapter 25 now after
tomorrow's death and over 150 chapters
after his initial debut we see him once
more he's a true trooper and insanely
loyal despite the fact that the cat must
be hurt it continues to march forward in
the direction of danger likely
determined to fulfill a final mission
this cat is definitely more awesome than
any cat I've met in real life even I a
dog person think it's amazing we then
get back into the epic fight between
moves on in the pillars we see eager to
fighting and moves on is even impressed
at how the snake pillar kicked away his
limb right after he cut it to prevent it
from immediate regeneration you might
remember that before
Milan's neck was cut and it just quickly
reattached however if someone was fast
enough to kick it off as it was being
cut it would be more difficult and
time-consuming four moves on to chase
after it or regenerate a whole new head
it's not much but iguodala showing us
that Mouzon isn't as untouchable as he
seemed at first eager earns a little
time with this method but as muslim
points out it's a very small amount of
time eager to mentions how avoiding
Mulan's attacks takes a lot of energy
even though there's a very long time
before dawn the pillars including agudo
are giving it there
all pushing themselves to their limits
and risking their lives in order to buy
even one more second
eager Oh looks like he is in great pain
he's sweating and he's struggling but he
knows that the pillars can't accept the
feet they are surrounded by their fallen
comrades and they need to do everything
they can to make sure that they didn't
die in vain or in other words for no
reason that's when we jump to Gil who
loses his sword to one of Mozart's
attacks just as ton zero got infected by
muslin cell destroying blood so did the
other pillars Gil's hands look heavily
infected to the point where he thinks
that he can't even grip a sword any
longer just when it seems like it's the
end for you
you know and Gil may with his wrecking
ball come to the rescue and destroy
moves on attacking limb Jimi's weapon is
arguably the most effective because
Mouzon can't just reattach the body part
like after a straightforward sword slash
the iron ball crushes a large portion of
his body rather than slicing it so moves
on has to spend more time and energy on
regeneration we see GU and he seems to
be staring helplessly Sunmi throws him
his sword and tells him not to space out
unless he wants to be taken out this
fight has infected hands with a painful
expression GU grabs his sword and starts
fighting again he tells himself that he
can do it he tells himself to pull it
together and make the battle one that he
won't be ashamed of I love this
mentality even though this battle seems
impossible and one second seems to last
for an hour the pillars are still
committed to doing the best that they
can even though it's hard and it seems
hopeless they will continue to do their
best as long as they can keep going even
if they're fated to lose they'll make
sure that they give it everything
they've got the only thing that would be
shameful and regrettable is quitting
before it was over then we get moves on
saying that the pillars outdid his
expectations they're holding out longer
than he expected them to but he's not
worried he thinks they'll be dead soon
enough and he points out that there is
still one hour and 14 minutes until dawn
keep in mind the pillars are trying
their best to just prolong the fight
until the next second and meet suti has
already been taken out and giya was
almost taken out and there's still
almost 4500 seconds left
things definitely don't look good for
our awesome pillars at this point
according to moves on they're less than
five minutes until the
cells of the pillars are destroyed and
they die since he says that they only
have five minutes it really doesn't look
good for Tangier Oh who's been infected
more severely by moves on cell
destroying blood and he's been dealing
with it for much longer
yo made the strongest pillar thinks to
himself that the situation is bad and
that they aren't going to hold out until
dawn
if the strongest one is thinking that
you can bet that the others are in even
more trouble Sunday me being the mad lad
he is is still thinking about how he'll
tear moves on a part until there's
nothing but a head left he's thinking
this despite the fact that moves on is
clearly way stronger than him son of me
is definitely coming off as a fearless
boss here and I like it after what
happened to his brother he is determined
to get revenge no matter how strong his
opponent is he looks like he's
struggling so much that he can't even
think and you got all worries about how
his small body is taking in poison
faster he knows that because of his
small size it will take even less time
for moves on cell destroying blood to
kill him then just when things seem
hopeless
timaeus cat makes an appearance jumping
above moves on moves line is caught off
guard for the first time in a while by
the feline the thing that the cat was
carrying on its back turns out to be a
kind of medicine for Mouzon cell
destroying poison the cat gets the
medicine delivered to the for fighting
pillars but then moves on does the
unthinkable he kills the poor cute cat
the cat bravely sacrificed its own life
to give the pillars and by extension
humanity a better chance against Musa
what a hero we see son amis face which
is horribly disfigured by the poison but
it starts to transform back as if he
just took a Senzu bean or something the
pillars notice that their bodily pain
has significantly diminished because of
the medicine that the cats delivered
Yomi realizes that the relief might be
temporary but he doesn't care since it
means that they can continue to fight
that's when Mouzon realized that the cat
and the medicine where Tom Leo's doing
she found a way to stop the effects of
moves on cell destroying blood he
comments as she continues to annoy him
even in death Tamiya has really been
amazing she was around since Judy she
fought wolves on and here she is way
later still participating in the story
even after she's been killed she helped
Shinobu defeat DOMA and now she's
helping the pillars against Mouzon from
beyond the grave news on was so assured
of his victory a second ago while
the poison was still kicking in but now
he's pissed he's going ham with his
demon tentacles and tells the pillars to
stop the use of struggling it's
interesting to note that Mouzon does not
seem to be toying with the pillars here
he's really trying his hardest to kill
them but he can't they're too good when
working together for moles on to be able
to easily finish them off this really
speaks a lot to the strength of the
pillars since they're fighting a moves
on that should be even stronger than the
one that you teach he fought because he
supposedly consumed way more humans
since then Musa definitely seems to be
getting close to hitting them but not
close enough the refreshed pillar
successfully dodged moves ons crazy
powerful and quick attacks you could or
thinks that he's doing the worst that
his record is the weakest and so he
wants to get in a more effective attack
he thinks about how when one's life is
at stake they can exhibit explosive
growth it's the idea that pressure makes
diamonds and that what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger you coulda reminisce
about how he had weak hands that only
ever held chopsticks before but he was
able to break out of his old jail cell
with a single hairpin he thinks about
how Toki tomu Ichiro only 14 years old
at the time turned his blade red until
the moment he died it's cool to see how
even though Mui Chino is gone his
virtuous death is still providing
inspiration for pillars and is helping
them fight better against Mouzon his
legacy lives on mucho proved that a
blade can turn red no matter what color
it is initially they can all eventually
turn red a color that the sword of your
Ichi the strongest demon seer in history
and first breath user was your Ichi was
a user of the strongest breath the
breath of the Sun so that would suggest
that red blades represent the power of
the Sun which as we know is every
demon's weakness including Meuse ons
if they can't wait for the Sun to come
out then the pillars might just have to
bring the power of the Sun to their
weapons in order to kill or at least
stall moves on long enough
thinking about muy tiro a demon slayer
mark finally manifests on egos body and
his sword begins to turn red yahuda
looks dangerous AF and I think during
the next chapter we are really going to
see what he's capable of
his last of the pillars present to
awaken a Demon Slayer mark and now his
sword is red too so it really seems like
they're hyping him up to be especially
powerful now I've been saying for a
while that ego has
gotten his time to shine in battle and
it seems like that time is finally
coming as I expected it would we also
know that the last time we chose blade
turned red Yomi and san amis blades
turned red soon after thus we may see
everyone's weapons turn red soon and
that might make their attacks much more
effective against Mouzon let me know
what you think where's this going and
how strong do you think eager is going
to be compared to the other pillars I
truly can't wait to see his full power
in the next chapter moves on already
seems to be having trouble dealing with
the pillars now that they are all
probably going to get a power upgrade
and the others including tundra and Ezra
codes I need two and so on might join up
soon it seems like Mulan is really not
going to be able to finish them off
unless he gets some kind of power
upgrade himself our demon slayers just
got to make sure that they don't let
Mouzon get away to fight another night
but anyways that was it for today's
video
another interesting chapter that seems
to be setting up for some especially big
developments in the next one I am
specifically excited to see Igor do his
thing that's gonna be dope even though
he mentions they used to be so weak it
has an especially small body it's
amazing to see how far he's come and I
have a feeling that in the next chapter
he will set himself up as one of the
strongest pillars and then hopefully
meet suti will be totally head over
heels for him if you enjoyed this video
make sure to smash that like button and
share with a friend because it really
helps with the YouTube algorithm if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
not know when new videos come out make
sure you follow anime uproar audio on
Spotify or Apple music since you can
download audio versions of all of our
videos now and we even drop the videos
there before we do here check the links
in description and if you are following
us already on those platforms the best
way to help us is to give us a five star
review wherever your listening a special
thank you goes out to our patrons on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole cos ASCII alpha do angel
Cruz and team Sparky 65 and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven n grata a lull on attempt
Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun the world steelers tyson
Kirino and the school bus thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits until next time see
you space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]